I think business and national security
writer Tim Chirac explores the
privatization of US intelligence mr.
Schirach contends that 70% of the US
intelligence budget is outsourced the
event hosted by the Institute for Policy
Studies in Washington DC is 75 minutes
okay well thank you very much for coming
out today for this event sponsored by
foreign policy and focus we are a
project of the Institute for Policy
Studies here in Washington DC we're a
network of over 700 scholars activists
journalists who take a critical look at
US foreign policy you can find us at the
web at www.www.pinesicearena.com was a
bulldog and it was I'm
sure a bad sign for the intelligence
community
when Tim shark decided he was going to
look at that issue the privatization and
outsourcing of intelligence here in the
United States
his new book spies for hire is as he
says the first non-fiction book about
outsourcing there's a novel out there on
this topic but this is the first
non-fiction book and we're delighted to
have him here I'll speak for about a
half an hour and we'll take some
questions and answers from you take it
away
Tamara okay thank you John
I want to correct one thing not all
journalists were lap dogs and in fact
there's one in the room who is one of
the best journalists in the country on
intelligence so thank you for being here
there's a lot of people in the press
that have really been focused on US
intelligence and have done an excellent
job of uncovering issues that's very
important to the public I want to say
it's really nice to be back here at IPS
the last time I spoke here was anyone
when I was sort of a future speaker was
in the mid 80s and I was speaking on
Korea actually at the time and there was
a guy in the audience who's very
clean-cut guy blond hair and I thought
well this gem must be from the Karadzic
foundation or something he was paying
very close attention he looked very very
straight very you know well-dressed and
kind of out of out of step with most of
the people had IPS anyway he came up to
me later turned out he was a Soviet
diplomat and it turned out he was he was
assigned to the Soviet embassy to study
Asia policy and a couple a couple years
later a couple years later there was an
expulsion of CIA agents from Moscow and
the u.s. retaliated by expelling a bunch
of KGB people from Washington and my
friend Egor turned out to be KGB so you
never know who you meet you never know
he'll you meet at IPs and maybe there's
somebody sitting here from an
interesting country or organization like
that anyway like John said I've written
this book and it's been a few years in
the making
I just wanted to talk a little bit about
how I got interested in this subject of
intelligence and outsourcing of
intelligence and then I'm gonna actually
read a little bit from my book and to
give you a little flavor of what's in
there and some of the key key issues I
bring up and then open it up for for
questions and answers
which is to me the most interesting
parts of events like this anyway like
John also said I'd been a journalist for
a long time I worked for over 15 years
in the business press and I worked for a
long time for a newspaper called the
Journal of Commerce which covered trade
global trade and transportation and when
I was when I was especially when I was
running there I've always been
fascinated by the interplay between
business / capitalism and foreign policy
and national security and so you know
how how how they work together and how
corporations basically made money out of
national security not so much the
lobbying part but kind of how they work
behind the scenes and and create these
organizations to further their policies
particularly in certain countries when I
was working at the Journal of Commerce I
got really interested in these
organizations that have these vague
names like United States Indonesia
Society and it sounds like this sort of
cultural organization but and actually
you know you look at them and who runs
them oftentimes it's you know former
high-ranking diplomats former
high-ranking intelligence officials and
they create these organizations to
further you know American policy into
their way of course in places like
Indonesia and and often in places where
the governments are authoritarian and
they want to sort of improve the image
of the government so there's this kind
of it's it's not lobbying it's just kind
of you know behind the scenes
maneuvering you might you might say to
to push certain kinds of policies and in
the early days of the this current Bush
administration I did a lot of reporting
I wrote one of the first in-depth pieces
about the Carlyle Group the private
equity fund there was
that we're at that time George Bush
Senior was a senior advisor and James
Baker the third people like that and I
looked at how they were drawing on their
own experience and their own and all
their contacts to make investment
decisions and in particularly in defense
and this was at a time when you know
like they they were they made very
clever decisions on selling some of
their operations at particular times
like just after 9/11 they did a IPO they
sold the stock in this one company
called United defense that made the
Bradley Fighting Vehicle and it's
perfectly timed for the the war that
Bush's son was about to start and and
they were also pretty invested in
intelligence so I was following this
this sort of phenomenon and then came
Abu Ghraib and the the prison abuse
scandal there and as was reported by
Seymour Hersh and others there were two
companies involved in Abu Ghraib and one
of them was a company called CACI which
is also known as as khaki international
and it just struck me as well first and
these companies were according to
military reports were deeply involved in
some of the worst abuse like khaki for
example some of their one or two of
their people had been and this is
according to later trials of people that
were lower-level people that were put on
trial and convicted there was testimony
at their trials that khaki personnel had
brought in some of the and encouraged
some of the worst practices at this
prison and one of them was introducing
you know dogs these attack dogs to
frighten and and basically terrorize
these these prisoners and it struck me
as outrageous that we had you know this
was like you know interrogation could be
like a profit Center for companies and
why are we why are we hiring these
private entities to do this kind of very
sensitive work that that really I mean
we saw in Abu Ghraib how much it damaged
that the nation's
you know what people the perceptions of
the United States over season we've
probably you know it's kind of take a
couple decades to recover from that but
I began to ask that choir choir
intelligence company is so involved here
in this kind of thing and I saw also
began looking at some of the key people
that this one particular company khaki
had on its board and there were advisors
and for example like richard armitage
who used to be the deputy secretary of
defense he had been on the board of
khaki and i kept finding these people
like that former high-ranking officials
who would go to these companies and so i
finally about as for one was at 2005 i
think it was i did a story for Mother
Jones magazine that looked at to you
know just this phenomenon an
intelligence outsourcing and who was
involved and how large it was and at the
time my conclusion was based on
interviewing a lot of people here in in
DC was that is about I estimated at the
time that about fifty percent of the
budget was being spent on on contractors
and it turned out to be quite a low
estimate because when I started when I
was doing this book and I you know was
hoping to get some figures from the from
the government from the intelligence
services intelligence community about
what how much was outsourced is really
the agencies basically wouldn't talk to
me and especially the the bigger ones
and they don't they consider a national
security secret you know how much
contractors they have even though they
have many many contractors there but
anyway about a year ago I was able to
get obtained a Declassified unclassified
this is a slide show that was put on at
a Defense Intelligence Agency conference
and one of the slides in this thing just
I just almost literally fell off my
chair when I saw because it was a big
pie chart and the pie chart in a circle
and there was like 70% and 30% a 70%
said contracts private contracts and so
when I checked up on this and actually
the office of Director of National
Intelligence
had produced this slide and I called
their press office and I finally got
someone to talk to me there and they
said yeah it's true it's 70 percent but
this covers everything from pencils to
satellites and they hemmed in hard and
but they still wouldn't give me any
dollar figures but in the won some of
these sometimes when you get PowerPoint
slides you can click you know you're
right clicker on your hundred house and
up up jumped a bunch of underlying
figures and in this pie chart and so it
gave actually you know numbers of how
much intelligence spending had been over
the last few years and it was astounding
at the time I think this was a year ago
and that figures are about you know and
of 2006 and it was something like forty
three billion dollars were being spent
then on intelligence contracts and and
that's and I think it's going up since
then so I give in the book I I give a
figure of about fifty billion dollars
that's what I estimate the industry to
be and it's a hard industry to focus on
as a as an industry in itself because
here in Washington nobody really covers
the intelligence industry specifically
as an industry you have to look at like
you know Washington technology which is
a publication of the Washington Post
covers information technology companies
so like a lot of intelligence
contractors or IT companies and they
they contract with the government so
it's a lot of the leading IT companies
are also leading intelligence companies
so you'll look at the whitey list the
top 100 they put out every year they
just put out one in Washington
technology about the week ago or so
you'll see you know Booz Allen Hamilton
science applications international
corporation Lockheed Martin these kind
of companies are the big you know IT
companies they're also the really big
intelligence you know companies and then
if of course if you look at the you know
top 100 defense contractors that the
same thing so you can sort of see who
the top defense and the top IT companies
are and that's generally who the top
intelligence contractors are
of course the difficulty in in in
tracking the industry is that something
like maybe it's 80% 75 to 80% of
intelligence contracts are classified
their secret often top-secret so it's
pretty difficult to actually you know
get hold of the contracts or get hold of
the you know even the aggregate known
figures for contracts and people often
won't you know won't talk about any
specific contract the only way you can
you can read they announce them but it's
often very kind of vague big language
like you know we the company will say we
just received 130 million dollars to
help fight the war on terror they don't
they don't tell you if it's NSA or CIA
or whoever it is but but in any rate
it's it's difficult difficult to track
but as I as you see in the book there's
lots of opportunity because so many of
these companies are publicly traded
companies you can buy and buy and sell
their their shares on the stock market
so they all have to file with the SEC
the Securities and Exchange Commission
they all have to file fairly detailed
reports like any company must and when
there's a material change in their in
their in their situation they all like
if they get a big contract or they lose
a big contract they have to report that
to the SEC so you can follow a lot of a
lot of what they do and sometimes annual
reports are are you know pretty detailed
about what they do it's and I got a lot
of information out of some annual
reports of certain companies and they'll
even say go into some detail about
specific agencies that they work for and
and and and and what they specifically
what they do often its jargon you have
to kind of cut through and understand
what they're talking about but the
information is out there so in a sense
the the moretz becomes a private sector
business the more you can actually learn
about intelligence it's kind of a window
it's a sort of a window into the
intelligence community and what they're
doing so it's just to just to kind of
give you a flavor I just wanted to
read from the the prologue of my book
where a lot of the reporting I did was
there there used to be a conference here
in Washington called
Intel con I think there was only helped
twice but it was sort of an open open
source conference on intelligence and
there's a lot of interesting speakers
and I picked up a lot of information and
met a lot of people there and I also
have gone to quite a few simple industry
symposia and also these symposiums they
have exhibits where you can you know
companies have on display what they put
in software that they make and that kind
of thing so there are there are
opportunities unclassified places you
can go and learn a lot about it so if
you bear with me a little bit I just
want to read a little bit for my for my
prologue on May 9th 2006 John Humphrey a
former CIA officer making his way up to
management ladder of one of the nation's
largest intelligence contractors made a
stunning disclosure to Intel Khan a
national intelligence conference and
exhibition in Bethesda Maryland
outsourcing Humphrey declared was out of
control
contractors deployed in Iraq and other
hotspots overseas were making decisions
and handling documents at an earlier
times had been the sole responsibility
of US military and intelligence officers
this had caused a quote paradigm shift
unquote in the relationship between
government and the private sector and
left companies like his in an untenable
position five years ago you'd never have
a contractor supporting an operation on
the field whether making a
recommendation to an officer said
Humphrey nor would you find a contractor
making little contributions here and
there and the reports intelligence
officers sent back to Washington this
concerns me a lot the way these lines
are blurring he went on we shouldn't be
involved in some of these intelligence
operations or the planning or the
interrogations and what-have-you unless
government started taking more
responsibility in the field he warned
and the blowback for the contracting
industry could be profound the
intelligence professionals in the room
looked stunned they had just sat through
two days of upbeat discussions about the
annual ten billion dollar expansion of
US intelligence budgets and the
opportunities that money presented for
defense contractors information
technology vendors and former national
security officials who still held their
top-secret security clearances upstairs
in the exhibition hall thirty-five
companies were displaying the latest
high-tech spying equipment and competing
to recruit new employees who could earn
up to three times government pay by
migrating to the private sector
words like blowback did not come easily
at such gatherings but this speaker and
the corporation he represented had an
exceptional story to tell
Humphrey was employed by khaki
International Inc a 1.8 billion dollar
information technology company that does
more than 70% of its business with the
Department of Defense for many years
khaki had been one of the Pentagon's
favorite contractors it was particularly
respected for its professional
evaluations of software and IT products
supplied to the military by outside
vendors during the late 90s khaki moved
heavily into military intelligence when
the Pentagon its budget reduced by
nearly thirty percent from the days of
the Cold War and unhappy with the
quality of intelligence it was getting
from the CIA began bringing in private
sector analysts for the first time this
proved to be appreciative for khaki when
nineteen Muslim fanatics linked to
al-qaeda steered three hijacked jet
liners into the World Trade Center in
the Pentagon on September 11 2001 in the
aftermath of the worst terrorist attack
in American history the intelligence
community began scouring Washington for
analysts covert operatives translators
and interrogators it could deploy in the
hunt for their perpetrators and to fill
the ranks of the hastily organized
counterintelligence centers at the
Central Intelligence Agency and other
government agencies khaki which already
had a small army of trained and cleared
intelligence
specialist holding security clearances
was perfectly positioned to pick up the
slack between 2002 and 2006 khaki signed
dozens of new contracts acquired 12
companies and more than tripled its
revenue from 564 million dollars a year
to nearly 2 billion dollars a year it's
astonishing growth catapulted the
company from a bit role in IT to one of
the key players in what has become a 50
billion dollar a year intelligence
industrial complex quote kaki is a
cashflow story Dave Greg it's C khakis
chief operating officer boasted to
investors in 2006 whenever you hear bad
news it's usually good news for us and I
talked a little bit in the next
paragraph how they got this kaki got
this contract in Abu Ghraib by buying
another company that had a contract with
the Pentagon and then I say that tasked
with the job of rooting out the leaders
of the insurgency some khaki employees
directed military interrogators to use
techniques on Iraqi prisoners that were
to put it mildly far outside the norm of
civilized conduct reports of the
mistreatment soon made their way the
u.s. commanders in Iraq who appointed an
army general to investigate conditions
of the prisoner and then this report
came out thrusting the Bush
administration into it one of its most
serious foreign policy crises and the
details of a lot of what happened there
you can read about and see more Bush's
to see more Bush Seymour Hersh his great
book sorry
chain of command and there was also a
film distributed last year you may have
seen I was distributed on DVD only I
think by Robert Greenwald called Iraq
for sale the war profiteers he had a
section on on khaki and I say oh you
know the reports focused on some of the
most brutal PAP practices and they
talked about khakis role particularly in
this use of attack dogs and and but the
problem was
you know the pictures themselves of
those attack dogs convinced US military
tribunals to convict two of the dog
handlers for assault no case was ever
made against khakis people however even
though one of khakis employees a former
prison guard named Steven Stefano 'its
was identified at trial as suggesting
the use of the dogs he has never been
charged with a crime and nor has khaki
itself instead the CEO of khaki went
after anybody who wrote about it and in
his opinion distorted the story and he
fought back with a vengeance attacking
journalists who printed stories about
the scandal generally castigating anyone
who dared to suggest that khaki bore any
responsibility for the abuse and
actually they've just khaki has just put
out a little little book about their
terrible ordeal with with this situation
they're still at it
trying to correct the story as they see
it and I'm sort of waiting for the legal
foot to draw from them because they seem
to have they seem to like to sue
everybody that writes about them but
then I talk about how you know despite
what's happened there they've gotten
huge amounts of contracts from the
Department of Defense since then and in
fact about three weeks ago they were
part of a very large set of contracts
awarded by the Defense Intelligence
Agency to eight different companies to
provide intelligence analyst an ALICE to
the DIA but the important part getting
back to this person from khaki who spoke
and his remarks Humphrey John Humphrey
this khaki person who had also worked
before he went to the company as a CIA
agent was careful not to accept or even
apportion any blame for what happened
the individuals involved in the Abu
Ghraib incidents as he called them had
the best intentions a contractor at an
intern in internment camp is in a very
stressful situation he said you're being
told you have to do this that you're the
only one who can do this contract
contractors he concluded need to settle
back to being in a supportive role
inside the government there's a little
too much right now of let's get a
contractor and life is good
there needs to be more of a setting of a
line to date his speech is the most
detailed and honest analysis of Abu
Ghraib to come from khaki and and I
conclude this part of it by saying that
what happened there and khakis refusal
to discuss what happened at our grave
stands as a kind of high-water mark for
intelligence contracting in 2006 the
Year Humphrey delivered his comments the
cost of America's spying in surveillance
activities outsourced to contractors
reached 42 billion dollars or about 70
percent of the estimated 60 billion the
government spends every year in foreign
and domestic intelligence unfortunately
we cannot know the true extent of
outsourcing for two reasons first the
Office of the Director of National
Intelligence refused to release an
internal report on contracting out of
fear that its disclosure would harm
national security interests and second
most intelligence contracts are
classified allowing companies like khaki
to hide their activities behind a veil
of secrecy
and that's how I begin and in the book I
go through pretty much all the key
agencies and and and what they do
including the Central Intelligence
Agency and the National Security Agency
the National geospatial Intelligence
Agency talked about the key companies
that work for them the sort of the
latter part of my book the last couple
chapters are about the NSA and the
implications of corporations being
involved in surveillance by the National
Security Agency this is something that
that as a citizen I feel particularly
alarmed about because you know we know a
lot about the telecom companies
cooperating with the NSA and and being
you know basically giving access to
their databases to the NSA and allowing
the enemy an essay to search through you
know millions of telephone calls records
of telephone calls and we also know from
testimony from ATT technicians that the
NSA basically built a pipeline to the
att's internet system in San Francisco
and other cities st. Louis as well where
they just you know copied everything
coming in on the internet so they you
know they have they have a lot
they've been analyzed
but that the telecom companies gave them
gave them access to this and now there's
still a big fight in Congress or whether
they should be given immunity about if
they broke any laws but I make this
argument in here that is there's all
these companies dozens of companies like
kaki international man Tech
International SAIC Booz Allen that
provide the analysis that do that they
actually scrutinize telephone calls for
you know clues supposedly to what a
terrorist group might be doing and
trying to basically they're essentially
what they're doing is trying to track
pre-crime like that Tom Cruise movie but
you have this huge you know group of
companies that are deeply involved in
analyzing this kind of intelligence and
I think you know if we're talking about
telecom responsibilities and in in terms
of what may may have been illegal
warrantless surveillance of Americans
those companies are also have have some
questions to answer I believe and we
need to look at them as well in that
whole industry I think is is very
important to broaden it out from the
telecoms to all these these IT companies
and finally the other issue that as part
of that is is the whole issue of
domestic surveillance and how it's being
and how NSA and other agencies that that
in the past always spied on on foreign
countries that was all always designed
to you know track you know the
conversations of Soviet leaders and
stuff like that and now we're were using
these where the government is using
these agencies to to try to find
evidence and and to track domestic
domestic evildoers or potential
evildoers as Bush calls them and I have
a story today running in salon about a
Saudi Arabian charity that had a had
there was a they had a relationship with
a very with a Islamic charity in Oregon
and the you know they of course the NSA
spied on
to track the telephone calls and
accidentally gave the document to
someone here in the room who's the
lawyer for the charity and this is a
little problem for them because it
opened the door for a law a major
lawsuit against the the NSA by this by
this charity but what really troubles me
and when I run about in this article was
how the they used NSA and whatever other
surveillance say they picked up to to
call this group and certain individuals
in Oregon terrorists a terrorist they
have a term called specially designated
global terrorists and people like that
they cannot they can't see the evidence
they can't see the classified evidence
they they have no way to challenge the
evidence there's not one single
evidentiary hearing where they can
challenge it and it's and it's this very
murky system where I think our justice
system has been turned on its head and
as I've been doing there doing the
reporting on that particular story I've
actually identified you know several
companies one actually I found the other
day when I was looking through some of
the Treasury Department material on it a
contractor called EG&G that they
contrary to contracted out some of the
analysis to but there's a couple other
companies I've identified so anything
anytime we're talking about foreign
intelligence domestic intelligence we
have to you know we have to understand
that there's many many companies
involved in this too and we remember
when we say that 70% of the budget goes
to these private companies that means
you know a huge proportion of our
intelligence work is being handled for
profit by by the private sector and this
raises you know to me a whole lot of
issues including civil liberties issues
that are very important for us at this
time so I'm going to stop there and take
questions and hope to hear some
interesting interesting ones David go
ahead
one of the interesting aspects of
outsourcing or privatization and you see
this
the debate over private military and
security contractors is that supposedly
there's a bright shining line what
people on the government side say this
is inherently governmental therefore
private sector should never do it it
should be reserved for the public sector
now merely that's pretty flexible line
but in the aftermath of Abu Ghraib which
you cite at least for a while they said
okay we believe Italy would come to the
recognition this is inherently
governmental tasks we should not have
firms like khaki or even to some extent
tightened doing translations do this
kind of work and under secretaries of
defense for intelligence you know went
back and say yeah we even put out a memo
on this years ago with Sarah but one
gets a sense when one looks at
intelligence contracting that they prove
that concept out the window I mean where
you know where if anywhere and I'm just
asking because they truly want to know
in the intelligence community you know
what is the function within all the
things that the intelligence community
does where they say this is inherently
governmental we can't allow private
contractors to do this and as a
follow-up to that when an intelligence
contractor does a task whatever it is
what does government do to ensure about
what they're getting is actually
worthwhile in other words what kind of
quality control do they do a teeming
with private military and security
contractors paretic is oversight
occasionally is at least occasionally
you get reports coming out of Special
Inspector General for a CBO Gao dod IG
etcetera you know if the CIA IG puts out
a report we in the public never see it
so those two you know boasting normally
governmental and where's the quality
control good questions and to the first
issue inherently governmental I quote in
here from a report from the House
Intelligence Committee last year when
they were drawing up the budget bill for
the intelligence community which was it
was never passed and was veto eventually
by President Bush nevertheless the
language is a
there and in the report accompanying
that legislation the House Intelligence
Committee said you know the government
has no standards at all on what's
inherently governmental and what it's
not they haven't even sat you know seven
years or ten years after all this
outsourcing nobody's within government
has gone and said okay what are these
tasks should just be left to our people
to the government and what's okay to
outsource they haven't done that at all
and I think that's a pretty sad
commentary that the discussion has not
apparently not even occurred within our
government as far as oversight goes I
think oversight of intelligence is not
the best it could be I think it's pretty
it's pretty loose anyway and it's and I
think there's a lot of things that
happen that that Congress isn't that
should be looking at that they're not
but when it comes to contracting it's
even harder because they don't even know
it
Admiral McConnell who's now the Director
of National Intelligence when he was up
for his nomination hearing and was a
january/february o7 somebody asked him
about about was asking him a little bit
about contracting and and the senator
was asking him said you know we here in
the Senate we have no idea how much
outsourcing is going on they don't have
any figures and and and so I don't
really understand how they can possibly
do their job without without knowing
exactly who's doing what you know what
agencies what percentage they contract
out so you know I think the the you know
in terms of reporting this story the
Office of the Director of National
Intelligence wouldn't really give me
anything the NSA wouldn't talk to me
CIA finally he lets someone talk to me
but they wouldn't identify my name it's
just some spoke generic spokesperson and
he wouldn't give me any figures there's
only a few agencies that will say how
much and like one of them is a to their
credit the Defense Intelligence Agency
which provides intelligence for the
Joint Chiefs and the Secretary of
Defense they say that 35 percent of
their workforce is contracted so at
least they give you they give you the
straight face
you're in the national
geospatial-intelligence agency which
provides imagery and mapping for
military and intelligence agencies they
told me also that their workforce is 50%
contractors there's another agency
that's highly secretive called the
National Reconnaissance Office which
manages military satellites and there
are 95% contractors so so basically you
know the workforce is there it's a huge
huge private sector workforce and I and
in in terms of oversight I think there's
some real issues with you know like for
example there's a story about the NSA
National Security Agency there's a
project called Trailblazer where they
hired a company called SAIC a very large
defense contractor to manage a project
which is which is to put it very simply
it was basically to try to draw lectrons
from all the cellphones and you know
internet that that grew up after the
late nineteen nineteen nineties that
project was really huge cost overruns
four or five billion dollars they spent
and basically it turned out a bunch of
junk and it was useless and then the
same company got the contract for the
follow-up project so you sort of wonder
about about things like that and it
turns up over so done great talks of
duck Brooks international peace
operations association I think you raise
some really key issues I guess my point
would be okay you look at the big
intelligence failures or weapons of mass
destruction and so on clearly something
needed to be done to improve
intelligence and I don't think the
government's ever allowed to fire anyone
even if you don't have these so seems to
me bringing the sort of
cost-effectiveness values from the
private sector makes a lot of sense now
I think your key points are really good
I mean you got to make sure the rules
are there they'll take oversights there
but essentially bringing that kind of
efficiency
some sort of sensor or why does the
government actually outsource at all I
mean what's our reasoning either well
that that's a good point I mean I think
that what happened and it was the you
know the outsourcing began long before
9/11 and there was there's quite a bit
of it in the late 1990s but I mean
essentially you know in the early 1990s
there was pretty big cuts to the defense
budget and the intelligence budget part
of the so-called peace dividend and
staffs at some of these places lead like
the NSA were cut like 30% CIA was cut a
lot of people left some of them went
into the private sector and and so there
you know the clearly that the the
intelligence community was was became
smaller than it was and and and for a
while that was no problem but when in
the second half of the Clinton
administration when the Clinton got
involved in you know the NATO Wars and
Yugoslavia and there was a sudden need
for intelligence analysts and all kinds
of intelligence that they that they
didn't help that they needed the people
in government simply weren't there
because the budgets have been cut and so
a lot of the institutional memory in a
sense was in the private sector so they
went to the private sector and started
hiring people and then of course you
know 9/11 there was this just like you
know enormous amounts of money were
thrown at the intelligence budget and
budgets increased you know 30% being a
forty percent a year for a few years
there and you know you had the same you
had the same problem I think the issue
is we as a nation and our Congress
really needs to figure out and think
what what kinds of functions are ok to
give to the private companies obviously
the government's not going to have a
factory to make you know u2's or
something like that I mean you know
private sector companies can provide a
lot of that kind of technology but in
terms of like you know the analysis
writing the reports and go up upstream
to high level people you know like the
president's Daily Brief do we want you
know your corporate logos over that I
would like to have you know a cadre of
government people that are there
to do intelligence that you know
year-to-year that we can count on to
give objective as much as we can hope
for
you know advice and intelligence to our
leaders I mean I think there's a we've
had so many problems with you know
intelligence being twisted to fit you
know Cheney's needs and whoever's needs
there when you have people working I
think it adds another dimension of that
when you get private sector people doing
it and I think you know who do they
answer who do they answer to and like
when you're a contractor you want to
please the person you know who gives you
the contract so I think it's
intelligence can be really stood in that
sense and there that's that's the
problem so I think we really have to
figure out you know what's okay to
outsource and what's not then it was the
interesting case it really cuts at the
heart of what you were talking about out
west all the National Labs are managed
by contractors DME contracts with
Lockheed Martin and then University
California Bechtel all these large
contractors in Incendia
there was an employee that was Shawn
carpenter that was tasked to actually
break into Lockheed's computers to see
who else was breaking it to actually do
games to find it out and he found out
that the Chinese hackers where there
were hacking into nat'rally like like
the Lockheed computers were okay at
Sandia but they were they were hacking
into computers at NASA DoD Chinese the
Chinese were the Chinese hackers and not
only it wasn't classified information
but it was export control information
which meant you had to get a license to
export it right so like he'd immediately
fired it and we think the reason was and
he wanted trial he won his case at trial
um however we think that the reason he
may did that is because China is a big
client of Lockheed and his supervisor
said to him you know we don't care about
these other agencies we just care about
Lockheed if we if if Sandhya's computers
are safe forget everything else and so
he went to the FBI the FBI had an on
investigation into the Chinese hackers
and used his information we're very
thankful but he gets fired by lucky
because like he wasn't happy that he was
giving that information to the FBI it
then comes out that China had excused me
the Lockheed had been fined for illegal
transport technology from the u.s. to
children without the proper licenses so
that's like an example of what you're
saying is there's no governmental
accountability about what's good for the
country
it's what's good for lacking or the
corporation and the end the company has
its own interest and you know furthering
relations with China and it could be the
same and different company could have
other interests elsewhere that it's
worrying about yeah and that's the
problem is that you know we reason I
want to have government people doing the
key intelligence work as I want the
person's loyalty to be to the government
they serve and us as a public and in the
nation as a whole not to their
shareholders is a company of a way to
make money and I think you know that's
that's a problem like there was a
someone from the New York Times there
was a great article about a year ago
about just how much outsourcing is going
on in the federal government it's about
last June I think it was and there was
an amazing interview that The Times got
with the guy who's ahead of the forget
which agency it is but it's an agency
that has oversight over you know
contracting within the government he
said you know yeah that's what he said
very boldly like you have you know one
when one entity is loyal to their
shareholders the entities loyal to the
government in the nation and sometimes
those things conflict I'm not saying
that you know private spies are
unpatriotic or whatever but they have
different you know different motivations
and different masters and that's the
problem
almost become a religious mantra in this
country that the private sector is
always more efficient
you ask 910 people in the street they
would just instinctively as their
privatization is always better and yet
it's ironic that the most widely
circulated photocopy comic strip in this
country is Dilbert which does nothing
but poke fun season the corporate in the
private sector and so it seems to me
there's a real cognitive dissonance
going on in the minds of the American
public and my question is how much of
this push towards privatization is
driven surely by a foreign court
ideological reasons but there are
sectors of the society that left
privatize everything from the moon to
the sidewalks all right you know which
which organizations are behind that do
you see and where is that push coming
from with leaving alone the issues of
efficiency and whatever but just purely
ideological pushing apologize that's
kind of hard to answer because I think
you know there's a hitless chapter in
the book about about the history of
intelligence outsourcing kind of a quick
history of it and I talked about how you
know Reagan started this privatization
Drive and but it didn't under Reagan it
really didn't go very far because he
didn't have much support from the you
know there was a Democratic Congress and
there was a lot of opposition to it and
he only the amount of government entity
see actually that were sold under Reagan
were very few but the real voice was
under Gunder Bill Clinton and you know
Clinton and gore had this this whole
initiative called reinventing
governments and make government more
efficient and you look underneath that
and there was all kinds of outsourcing
went on and critically in defense they
were outsourcing all kinds of things
they were selling whole entities to
private companies and from his
perspective I guess it was you know make
government better to serve the people as
real efficiency kind of thing but but
underneath that was all this outsourcing
and I think and then and they kept
commissioning there was like three big
studies done under Clinton you know okay
what should we do about outsourcing and
what's go okay to outsource and they're
all run by you know you know like Frank
Carlucci from The Carlyle Group or any
other these people like that has a big
stake in it and then they're all
advising the Clinton ministration to
move forward on this and they all have
companies that are benefiting from it
you know and so I think there's sort of
from you know Clinton's that could never
quite figure out Clinton's ideology
anyway but
if he had one but but so it for their me
for him is like efficiency or whatever
you know but I think on these you know
bush-cheney it was driven also by this
you know feeling that that that it was
fine to you know outsource the whole
occupation of Iraq and you know no
problem these companies will do it
really well and so on but but I think
the you know you can see you can see
that the amount of outsourcing just kind
of steadily going up from from the late
mid nineteen nineteen ninety so and
surely it's gonna continue obviously you
can't just you know the government's
some agencies are trying to employ you
know more hire more of government people
and you don't have people within the
within their agencies the CIA for
example the last year said they put a
ten person they said they want to cut
contractors there by ten percent and I
think that they're starting to seeing
the agencies that there's a problem they
even even Hayden who's the Michael
Hayden who's the director of the CIA now
he said something like you know we've
become the farm team for contractors and
they real you know they recognize that
it's a problem you know I mean they had
a kick
they had a kick a bunch of companies out
of the CIA cafeteria because they're
like recruiting intelligence officers at
lunchtime you know and then they're in
they're in jail will give you two
hundred thousand you make one hundred K
will give you two hundred K that kind of
thing and they had to get rid of these
guys because so it's even begun to tick
people off within the government I think
and I and I can imagine that I mean
there was a few people I spoke to who
you know we're kind of you know upset
about the whole trend people longtime
intelligence officer is you know but you
know but then there's there's a lot of
people that just say well what else can
we do you know we have to do it and and
I think that I mean I I also think we
have to kind of back away for and look
what is our intelligence for what do we
use it for I mean there's a lot I mean
I'm not just because something should
not be outsourced doesn't mean I approve
of you know the CIA doing covert actions
I'm trying to overthrow some government
that should be done by the government
rather than
company it it's like it shouldn't be
done at all
you know but do we want to have Lockheed
in there trying to overthrow some
government well I don't think so but do
we want the CIA doing it no we don't
either so we have to think about you
know intelligence as you know how is it
used and I think that the big issue in
terms of over oversight and how it's
used is is the fact that 85% of the
intelligence budget is controlled by the
Pentagon and that so much intelligence
is integrated with military operations
and they have command and control over
the big agencies and you know I think
like in the imagery agency the national
geospatial-intelligence agency they the
stuff the stuff they have the available
is unbelievable the technology you know
in mapping and the overhead and imagery
from you know u2's or satellites and
that stuff can be used for so many good
things you know like tracking refugees
or a situation like Darfur where you can
you can actually see villages that have
been raised and destroyed I mean that's
that's the kind of intelligence that we
need you know to see what's going on in
places around the world
not necessarily to you know track people
traveling around the United States or
you know tracking people for military
purposes I think so so in a way we
really you know I feel like we really
have to evaluate what intelligence is
used for intelligence gathering and
analysis if you have found that the
private companies have a particular
orientation or a particular bias that's
different from that of the federal
intelligence agencies do they tend to
exaggerate threats more or less are they
generally worse at the job then say
experience CIA analysts I mean does it
make a difference in terms of the
intelligence product well I think some
of the companies yes are are different
like I have a chapter in here called the
plays and the pure plays or companies
that it's a Wall Street term for
companies that are focused just on one
particular industry that make you know
70 80 percent of their revenue from one
thing like Coca Cola's of pure play
because all they do is sell soft drinks
and some of these companies are pure
play intelligence companies because
that's pretty much all they do and one
of them is a company I talked about
khaki international and and I have
quotes in here from khaki that'll you
know it's just their ideological where
they're coming from ideologically is
pretty extreme I think and and that's
one company where you really see I mean
he's just posed you know the language of
the neo cons of Rumsfeld preemption is
all wrapped up in their in their
language you read in their in their
reports and annual reports and so on and
and so like I would really question you
know with their analysis because they
come from this the ideological place
other companies are not so much like
that they they you know they tend to
focus on you know what the government
needs or they don't they don't get into
like the roots of of it so much but I
think you know the the problem is you
have to wonder when they reap reports
for the government about you know
terrorism or terrorist threat in one
place or another how serious you know
how we should accept that information
since they have a lot to gain from
claiming that it's a really serious
threat you know so I and I don't really
it's hard to determine how that's
playing out like I was frankly surprised
and and you know happy to see when you
know madman McConnell put out that
report the well the National
Intelligence Estimate on Iran maybe when
was a six or eight months ago where they
said you know Ron stopped making nuclear
weapons and oh three whatever whatever
the day was you know that was that was
showed that there were you know
apparently he was giving you know at
least telling truth to power it
certainly didn't make Dick Cheney very
happy and Dick Cheney's of
they brought in mcconnell so i don't
think you can automatically say i can
automatically say you know just because
they're private they're their
intelligence is skewed but i think it
really raises a serious question about
you know other companies and what they
do and how skewed intelligence is and i
think we want we want to be assured that
intelligence is not skewed and that that
our leaders get the the right and the
right intelligence so they can make the
right decisions well the US has a really
tight relationship with the UK
intelligence and UK british companies
are very involved and they've actually
outsourced quite a bit there and some of
the big companies over here that are
involved in the intelligence market for
example bae systems which is the US
subsidiary of bae which is a huge
defense contractor they're very big here
in the intelligence market a company
called kinetic that was spun off from
the british defense and research
organization was privatized and and the
Carlyle Group actually bought them five
years ago or so and then put a lot of
capital into them and they and they
bought about six companies and they've
become a really big player but another
company other countries are doing it but
not know we're really near the extent
that the US and and UK it's pretty much
confined here although the last couple
days I've been interviewed by Australian
radio and this reported from Australia
was telling me how much outsourcing is
going on there
and they're they're actually asking me
about there's a story that broke on
Friday about Carlyle Group which has
been getting out of Defence recently
they're buying the government services
unit of Booz Allen Hamilton which is one
of the really big intelligence
contractors so they're kind of getting
into it and apparently Booz Allen has
major contracts in Australia but of
course Australia and New Zealand Canada
UK it's all part and the US are all you
know
they share intelligence they're very
very very very close and intelligence no
other US has realized it's only really
those english-speaking countries those
those that the US has the closest ties
with and that's where I think
outsourcing has expanded the most you
were saying that that the House
Intelligence Committee is decided that
there really aren't any clear lines
there's actually there's a bill up now
representative David price of North
Carolina and I forget her first name but
it's Schakowsky from Illinois jun-chan
excuse me
Jen okay I'm sorry they have a joint
bill before the house right now that
would exclude contractors from
interrogations exclude contractors from
being involved in the rendition program
and and some other and they wanted to
have some you know firm figures every
year from the intelligence community
about contracting and and and I think
David Price who I interviewed before the
book and I talked about his attempts
earlier to do it I think that's that's
that's that bill has a very good chance
of passing this year so at least they're
gonna create some standards but it
really is you can find this house
intelligence report from oh seven on you
know in the House Intelligence Committee
it was just the bill was just never it
was vetoed by Bush so it never became
law but the whole language in there is
very strong I mean they just say just
say you know they haven't they have no
standards for what's inherently
governmental and what's not so clearly
some people over there are concerned and
want to have you know some better idea
of what's okay to outsource and what not
to
but you see or do you know if the
contracts all these you know multitude
contractors have indemnity provisions
like for the telecom companies have
indemnity provisions uh-huh I don't know
that I don't know they must have some
language about that if they're like you
know
well yeah already involved in anything
that may be potentially illegal they
must have like with lots of line
contracts about the potential liability
and things like that but it is
interesting sometimes you can see like
if you find in the sec of course they
have people you know companies have to
report to their shareholders about risks
right and there's always a section about
in contractors big companies like Booz
Allen or any any government contractor
about risks and like I found a couple
you know just SEC has a pretty good
search engine you can you can search the
whole terms put them in quotation marks
eyes like I found a lot of people
individuals who were part of
intelligence companies like you know
George Tenet you didn't certain you find
out companies director Rev but like they
they all have language saying you know
we made like for a little telecom
company we may be involved and that the
National Security Agency may ask us to
provide information under a program that
may raise liability issues in the future
and they just have to warn their
shareholders about it so I'm sure it's
you know companies put stuff in their
contracts about that very issue but I've
never seen a contract physical class for
me I don't have a security clearance and
I'll probably never get one so
we traded but my impression that quotes
the following is that is that the
movement among contractors is going
private so that they can keep their
their you know their information and
their activities private is that the
Kaiser well if you're privately-owned if
you're not publicly traded you don't
have to file with the SEC and there's a
few companies that are like for example
Booz Allen Hamilton is it's not publicly
traded it used to be but it's not
anymore
SAIC which is a major contractor they
went public about a year ago maybe two
years ago so they no not really
I'd say most of the companies by far are
publicly traded and so that's that's
where you can find out a lot of
information but under negroponte a when
he was the Director of National
Intelligence he put out sort of a
guidelines for and for intelligence
contractors where they don't they don't
have to spell out two contracts the
specifics of their country he gave them
a waiver from SEC rules about spelling
out the specifics of their contracts so
like you know for they don't have to say
if it's for the CIA or something so like
I mentioned in the book how these
contracts are often the news if you read
a press release like a company like
khaki or manTech you read their press
release it's really vague about what
they're doing exactly you know 130
million to help fight the war on terror
you know really know you know who are
they doing what and then so they don't
have to say a whole lot about it they
can be they can be pretty vague but the
thing is you got to some of these
websites and and and also I found the
most interesting conferences events that
would go to are these places where they
do these presentations for investors you
know and and and they there's a certain
kind of hubris that takes over and
privado and like like there's one
company you know they're bragging about
how they make this one kind of software
and and they had always said in their
reports this one cuz this company called
man tech they make a software that's
that that intelligence agencies used to
where people of different levels of
classification can get unclassified or
classified and classified information on
one screen so if you have a high level
classification you can see your
information if you have a lower level
you can see it and by by showing what
classification you have and they had
always said that that the first product
they made was for the National was for a
National Security Agency right a agency
they never spelled it out but I went to
this one conference and the guy said
what we started out making this for the
NSA you know and then he went on to say
how they solved to the Defense
Intelligence Agency and then somebody
else so actually he was probably
blurting out a something that was
classified at that at that session so
there's a certain sometimes they like to
brag you know what their what they're
doing and you get information
information that way but actually if you
go you're like you know go on the khaki
International website it's fascinating
you know going and go to there they have
all kinds of stuff on there and
sometimes they put when the guy gives
the CEO gives a radio interview they
keep it up there and they don't think
you know anyone's gonna go in there like
I did and you know actually tape the
interview and then transcribe it you
know but but you can you know he talks
in detail and I quoted him in the book
you know what they're doing with signals
intelligence and I think it gives a
pretty good sense of what they're doing
they're doing what every agency what all
the agencies do know okay
drive an enterprise sometimes hit this
obviously not true hunk of it and
actually reacting in contrivance the
purpose of tired for I'm not familiar
with the military for the international
spy situation but I am very familiar
with resolutions by private places and
they're much much more costly the
besides having to not parole prisoners
because the stockholders would make as
much money hundred or more people behind
bars
is there any concept that this is
costing a hell of a lot in your area but
we look at Congress is debating these
supplemental appropriations to build a
bridge at last it goes nowhere but
there's all this going nowhere being
diverted millions not just
I mean it's just it's just it's just
starting really I mean I think that's
why some of these Congress people are
looking for this legislation passed to
get you know to get some control over it
and get you know to be able to question
an intelligence people about you know
exactly how this is helpful for their
agencies because last night how it's
like usually you think about outsourcing
you know corporations even lots of
governments they be outsourced and
because they pay people you know you
sent it to India because it's cheaper
right missing Labor's paid you know one
you know ten percent or whatever
American workers so outsourcing is
generally thought of as it's a big cost
saving kind of thing right well in terms
of intelligence its outsourcing cost
more I mean it's it's it's you know it's
like some of these guys some of these
people get paid double or even triple
what they would make at the government
and sometimes are sitting next to a
government person and I'm making you
know double or triple what the
government person is making so you have
to wonder about that and then of course
you know the the corporation is to make
its profit so there's a is even more
money also the the individual might be
paid two hundred thousand and the
company you might get one hundred
thousand for that person being there so
like you have to wonder about about the
cost of it what what people in the
agencies will say is you know are people
that support this will say as well you
know like it's CIA if you have someone
who's a drunk and they're you know you
can't they're there for 10 years and you
have to Sunday and keep track them you
can't fire them right because they're
government employees so if there's a
contractor that's drunk you know they're
out the next day so I suppose that's you
know one way to you know it's easier to
fire people but but I I think that the
the I don't really see the efficiency
savings I can I can understand it for
highly technical projects and you know
that the government
simply that that that isn't inherently
governmental but I can't see it for a
lot of the analysis I mean I just think
this you know there's this idea of this
I level analysis being done for
contracts for by contractors is wrong
and and that you know I quotes the woman
who wrote the fiction book on that on
this is it her name is r.j. Hill house
and she's an interesting writer and she
writes you know from from some expertise
she knows what she's talking about and
like I quarter is saying you know the
president's Daily Brief should look like
a NASCAR khaki here in Booz Allen or
whatever it
I mean it's it really it really is lots
of corporate input into those kinds of
things and and I you know I think that
high-level analysis which is what army
as well as their involvement in the
domestic surveillance and questionable
intelligence practices easy to figure
I'm get back to the area yeah I know but
what it costs to keep a prisoner locked
up for a crime domestic Clayton what it
would cost is extinct continue to run
government and it's it's right there it
cost much more it's also happens to be
worth less efficient because of the
inside of the taking people are you know
getting back to somebody else has you
know you know I in terms of like how
Corp how corporations may make their
pitch and whether we should trust that
or not you know a lot of what they do in
terms of analysis analyzing intelligence
you know the government wants them to be
able to predict crime essentially it's
you know it's it's looking at trying to
pre-crime it's it's it's that Tom Cruise
movie and and they're doing it I mean
they they they'll don't listen to phone
calls and they'll try you know and we
have the best software to track
relationships and they they just run
these programs as if they're gonna be
able to predict someone's actions in the
future and stop it from happening
and I really look at all the while they
look at the lack of real convictions
we've had in this country of anybody
really for serious terrorist actions
they've tried a lot of people they've
indicted a lot of people but a lot of
times the evidence you know goes to the
court and the courts many times quit the
people because the evidence just isn't
there and you know you can't just throw
in a bunch of intelligence and say well
they you know they had ten calls to be
sort of questionable organizations like
that doesn't prove anything
and I think that there's too much cars
rated nevertheless
I'm not saying that but there's a lot
cases where people the government's do
you know mash crops gone out there and
like you know like there was a case I
wrote about in this in this long piece
today about this Saudi PhD computer
student in Boise Idaho
you know Ashcroft came out and said this
guy's you know he's creating internet
sites websites that are aiding terrorism
all over and so on and so forth and they
put him in solitary confinement for 17
months and tried him and Boise jury just
didn't buy it and they acquitted him on
and pretty much all they meant serious
charges and then the government had to
drop the rest of the charges and he left
the country but I mean there's been a
number there's another case the Holy
Land Foundation and other charity where
they had intelligence and said they were
a front for Hamas and they were doing
this and that and a Dallas jury
acquitted acquitted the top people there
you know and and I just think that the
problem is when you get these companies
saying you know we can predict you know
we our software is gonna be able to help
you track all these terrorists and and
it's just I think it's data mining it's
called and I just think it's it's
hocus-pocus and I think it doesn't work
I think you know we if we're gonna
convict people go back to the
old-fashioned you know what's wrong with
like finding evidence and convicting I
mean you know you don't you you want it
you want to stop it and attack before it
comes but at the same time I think you
want to have a justice system that's
just and and I think we're moving in the
opposite direction and I think
corporations or corporations are helping
to fuel that by saying they have the
secret to you know to tracking to
tracking all these terrorists I mean you
go to one of these intelligence
conferences and go see their stuff I
mean it's just like that's out of this
world you know I'm like oh you know as
you go to Raytheon a huge screen and
they'll say oh look you know here's
these insurgents running around and see
we can see them and then there's a
little red thing and it's blinking and
they can in and and and you know so like
yeah yeah well so how do you know this
person is an insurgent or
you know this person is this or that
well you don't know they don't know that
they can't get inside the guy's head and
see if he's you know a Sunni Islamic
whatever and they can't do that they can
find they can look at people you can
track people very well with a lot
incredible detail but I had one of these
conferences I heard Admiral what's not
Admiral generals any who's this Marine
Corps general he was saying you cannot
track intent you can't find you know you
can't do surveillance and find intent
you can't you can't do that you can't
with it we don't have the technology to
get inside people's brains yeah I guess
they're working on it but but you know
that so like you go to these things and
you realize there's a whole lot of
software being thrown out there that's
it's prominent that they they promise
all kinds of things and then I've heard
people like military people who are you
know speak of these conferences they're
they've just been come back from Iraq
service there and they and they say like
just stop throwing this just software
crap at us you know it's just it's not
it's useless you know we just mean you
know some of them say forget this
electronic mapping it's we want to have
it on paper so we can you know go like
this and you know they did it make the
old kind of old-fashioned technology
often works much better than all this
fancy stuff so I think we're also
wasting a lot of money on on technology
that's unproven and not much use really
we have time for one last question
Tim thank you for this fascinating and
thanks for your research I guess I
wanted to go back to the more political
question do you have any
any indication what would you either
advise a transition team coming forward
or what would you predict in terms of
the remaining candidates in is it
possible to to turn the corner go in a
different direction in terms of this
intelligence outsourcing them what would
you say well in terms of like some kinds
of the outsourcing like I heard Obama's
military advisors speak a couple months
ago general mcpeak I think his name is
Gordon McKeon he just blasted the idea
of security contract and he said it's a
disgrace you know we shouldn't be doing
this etc etc so he seemed to have very
negative feelings about about that on
the other hand one of Obama's Obama's
top intelligence advisor is a very big
very big in the intelligence contracting
community I'm not sure you know how much
influence that would have an unbuttoned
shirt would have some you know and like
they're clearly not gonna just come in
and just say okay if we can you know cut
it all out but McCain I'm assuming
Hillary Clinton is dust now okay but as
far as the presidential run goes but but
McCain has some advisors that are you
know I'm pretty involved in this much
more involved in Obama he's advised by
james Woolsey and one of his top
national security advisors is Woolsey
Woolsey is really into making money on
him I think walls he's probably the
world he should run the world record for
best national security capitalist around
because he's Israeli he makes money from
everything he talks about whether it's
you know bioterrorism or whatever you
know he's there he's making money off of
it and I also think he's a bit of a
lunatic and and like like McCain is but
but but you know it's it's really hard
to gauge how people like that would be
influenced by the people around them I
mean sometimes you take their advice for
certain things you know but but clearly
someone at some point has got to say
okay let's get a look at
this let's get some control over it
anybody who wants you know to have a
better American national security policy
will have to take a look at that I would
think and and hopefully there'll be you
know that someone will take a hard look
at it whether it's a Republican or a
Democrat well Tim thank you very much
you've given us a peek inside this book
but there's so much more inside here and
selling book this is for sale and I
highly recommend this book and as Tim
unfortunately pointed out this is not
going to be reversed tomorrow so we're
gonna need a map to this new world of
intelligence outsourcing so please buy
the book and please and I'll and Tim
will sign it and please thank Tim for
sharing
Jim Chirac has written on business at
national security for over 20 years his
writing has appeared in several
publications including Mother Jones
salon and the nation he was also a
reporter in the Washington bureau of the
Journal of Commerce for more information